John Greg you belong in a museum no ticket guys
what's this is a title for it yeah Destiny I'm
learning this right now on camera I didn't know
that ladies and gentlemen we got ourselves a
minute 43 second trailer let's watch it what I
asked right now is you guys leave a like I found
this jacket in the closet it's the closest thing
to semi-resembling Indiana Jones I can let's do it
I miss the desert
laughs
I miss the sea whoa whoa it was
like pirates pirates five yeah
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the new
day will bring to us sawa's voice I think it's
solo yeah I hear you're supposed to be in those
days of yeah come and gone Perhaps Perhaps not
let's go and believe in magic
a few times in my life Phoebe
wow wow that was amazing
what you believe
it's during Apollo 11. hard to believe
foreign
look at him go yeah get back
let's go that looks awesome it's a great
reversal on the classic scene damn that
the Aging was shocking you know what I could
not get over how great that looked it was like
mind-blowing and I was not prepared at all but
mads Mickelson's in this flashback too is this
gonna deal with oh there's internet even notice
him that time is it gonna deal with time travel
in some way ah you know I wouldn't put it past
them I'm not 100 certain I mean maybe it just
dives into you know a part of Indy's history
or whatever but also I mean being that it is
the space race I don't know it's because mads
Mickelson doesn't look I guess he's a little
de-aged here yeah okay I guess men's Nicholson
that was a little bit because it's just way less
yeah the 1960s gonna be the backdrop Indy being
a man out of time here I mean it looks like it
has the spirit of Indiana Jones I like the fact
that this one will be dealing with his age it
works to its strength you know even when we saw
some like top gun Maverick where Tom Cruise was
like phenomenal at his age but I like how that
even that movie dealt with the fact that he is
older now and they're really leaning into that
and then here Harris Ford's gonna be like 80
by the time this movie comes out the way he's
moving here you know I remember like watching
the force awakens and Blade Runner 2049 and well
I think he did a great job in both those movies
there was stuff off about the way when he was
moving from like showing but in this trailer I
don't know maybe they just found the right Clips
I'm like no he looks like he's moving like back
in now I want to say his prime but it looks like
he's moving better than he did in those movies too
oh sure it makes me wonder I mean if the de-aging
technology alone is so crazy I wonder what they're
maybe able to do with stunt performers and maybe
you know attaching his head to them or maybe he
just really you know wanted to throw down and
get as limber as possible for this but I'm glad
that it looks like he is still capable and he
is still filling the shoes in a way that's not
gonna be like a bummer to watch yeah you know just
like the whole aesthetic too because you know you
associate Indiana Jones with a lot of what you
get here these like temples and these you know
uh statues and these ancient artifacts but also
Nazis that's right you gotta get those Nazis in
there especially nowadays yeah some famous rapper
out there is having a great time with this trailer
today who's that I couldn't imagine who the guy
who deserves to burn that's who I'll say I also
appreciate seeing Indy in the context of yeah like
the Apollo 11 parade and things that are more uh
you know at least more in Civilization that's like
you know a little bit of a different place than
we're used to seeing Indiana Jones but because
it's the period and because of what the movie is
dealing with it seems like a clever place to also
you know kind of expand the palette now who is
Phoebe Waller bridge going to be the goddaughter
of I mean not the goddaughter because that's
his goddaughter so he's got to be the daughter of
someone it could be I mean marrying cream or is it
uh or is it Marcus Brody yeah that's a good that's
a good one because it looks like it's tying it all
in and I think the best Indiana Jones movies are
often the ones that have uh that have something
to do with the Nazis seem to be the best ones yes
there's something weirdly about that and it looks
like they're going back to the time of Raiders of
the Lost Ark I just can't dial the destiny and I
just I don't know I get Time It's gotta be that
something and they're dealing with unless it's
just the backdrop to it but they seem to like play
with the actual events at hand I'm not saying he's
gonna have like a time machine or something
like that I have been here for it I'll watch
Jules Vern's Indiana Jones I don't know if they're
gonna do that thing where Phoebe Waller bridge is
gonna be handed off the Reigns here or something
like that people love that but this is the first
movie that Spielberg is not directing out of
the Indiana Jones franchise and this seems to
have like the earmarks of the great James Mangold
action sequences like James mangle I think I like
every every one of the movies I've ever seen him
do even ones that aren't that highly rated like
night and day I like everything this guy does
he seems like the love for Indiana Jones Is On
full display here but he's also bringing his own
Panache to the screen bringing Boyd Holbrook over
from Logan into here looks great mads Mickelson
as a villain not what not Typecast I'm getting
Vibes of the forgetting the guy's name to do
with the burnt hand the first one oh yeah yeah
something simple isn't it like probably I forgot
his name but I'm getting semi Vibes of him there
too I'm not gonna pull it you should look at
him yeah look it up but it makes me wonder
if they might do something like that like I I
really trust James mangle to deliver something
that is you know like an authentic story that
isn't you know too much in this sort of like
hey reference isn't cash crap but at the same
time I do wonder if we may be going back into
a time period of Indiana Jones that we're already
familiar with and maybe digging out some kind of
detail or you know something that was happening
uh concurrently that will then inform this new
adventure or something like that I also I hear
this is going to be the last movie that John
Williams is going to be scoring apparently
like ever I think yeah like last movie wow
yeah that'll be exciting damn yeah taught
hey I guess it would yeah just I have a I
have a decent memory of Indiana Jones because I
studied for the schmodown for it yeah that's good
so that's why I have like a good memory of it even
I haven't visited the films in a while either way
man I mean I thought this was actually a really
excellent trailer yeah I thought it was I thought
it was really Grand and exciting and it looks
beautiful and Harrison Ford seems really excited
about it and he looks like he really showed up
to play so you know it doesn't look like you're
just kept phoning it in from the enthusiasm
you talked about a d23 I feel like it'll be
an exciting time I do too but guys what did you
think about the Indiana Jones trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like click that Bell Also let's end this with a
David Gandy you just seem like the guy to shout
out when it comes to Indiana Jones you just
I think I think we've talked about Indiana
Jones before yeah it's just when it comes to
like swashbuckling old-timey films you're easily
the one in our patreon page to think of and dude
um I know you're uh you're a Christian man and
I hope that this Christmas season you have a
Splendid Christmas with uh the family you're able
to be with and I hope you actually attend church
that day yeah I want that for you three hours
I want you to go to that three hour Candlelight
visual yeah no don't you don't it's supposed to be
like serious somber Christmas it's not Catholic Oh
Chris Christians so he gets to have like a Monica
more joy than we they're gonna have like a band oh
they're gonna have like a lively yeah Christian
Church is fun oh I'm not even a Christian but
I've been to Christian churches in Christmas
and they are fun Indiana Jones it is like a
Church concert event um not like what we grew up
with I know anyway David so I had a crush for us